after one trillion euros gets lost every
year due to tax evasion and fraud but
how to shed light on the tax practices
of multinational companies during the
many plenary in Brussels Commissioner
Moscovici presented proposals on
compulsory information exchange between
member states epic I you just don't look
she's gettin 36 my cervix and repository
quito sistema this for Apophis era en
esto quiere más not lecture me k na KO
myo so buruma 80 strips Kate operator
aboot parking anacin Veneto tax
harmonization between member states was
also one of the key issues we serve an
estimate gauge startin the under
assistance in direct assistance the
Commission keine installation a
harmonious younger Madame escape niche
Australia harmony among our forum live
or sun an ocean is reminder strategy
gagan star damping or Giga destroyer for
my Emmy peas gave the thumbs up to an
action plan on tax policy the next step
is to convince member states to fight
tax evasion more effectively